what would you say to people that maybe  don't get why maybe jokic's got the MVP  over someone like indeed what makes  yogic so special besides the numbers the  amount of possessions and games  throughout the seasons throughout two  years of him winning MVPs it's crazy if  you actually go and watch the games he's  got a guy on them  Defender coming from here sometimes  Defender coming from here he's able to  look this way and throw a pass and he's  got three guys on him like it's not easy  it's not just because he's passing the  ball or he's not doing too much work  like he's creating everything for us  literally everything so to watch him do  that possession after possession the  playoffs like it's it was pretty  incredible and to have the consistency  to do it is another thing I don't think  anybody else should have won it over  over yoke I really don't